[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
avrei voluto iniziare questa ted top
come si conviene con una frase molto
effetto però deciso che siccome quando
si parla di design si parla sempre
spesso di serie di tavoli
forse avrei fatto una piccola premessa
per spiegare un attimino che cos'è
design molto breve
io credo che per la maggior parte di voi
il design sia questo degli oggetti molto
belli molto costosi spesso con
funzionalità non proprio chiare come
questo spremiagrumi di philippe starck
però design e anche tutto questo cioè
tutto quello che vedete intorno a voi è
stato progettato
sto parlando della cultura diciamo della
della produzione di massa di oggetti
industriali tutti questi oggetti sono
stati pensati dai designer e ingegneri
che hanno aiutate le aziende a portare
alla manifattura che cosa significa
questo e arriviamo alla frase come dire
quella effetto con cui avrei dovuto
iniziare la top che il design è in
qualche modo anch'esso responsabile per
il cambiamento climatico
sembra come dire una frase un po assurda
perché come si può collegare una cosa
del genere
una cosa del genere ho tutte le cose
bruttissime che ci stanno succedendo in
questo momento a livello di ambiente con
chi disegna le siede ai tavoli o i
vostri smartphone iphone
in realtà il legame molto serrato perché
il design come vi ho detto è una delle
discipline che fin dalle origini
dell'industria ha caratterizzato
l'industria stessa design aiutato che
industria manifatturiera a produrre le
cose meglio a produrle in modo più
decente più bello e soprattutto a
venderle meglio
tutto questo è sempre stata la verità in
un'economia che è quella che viviamo
oggi c'è un'economia capitalistica in
cui lo scopo delle aziende a fare
profitto e che si basa soprattutto su
una funzionalità lineare della creazione
del valore
sto parlando della differenza tra
l'economia lineare l'economia circolare
in cui nella prima che quella in cui
siamo oggi nella maggior parte dei casi
il valore viene creato attraverso
l'estrazione di materiali dalla terra
la lavorazione è qui nella
trasformazione in prodotti e poi
bacchetta mento di questi prodotti alla
vendita e cosa succede alla maggior
parte di questi prodotti alla fine vita
che finissero una discarica percentuali
bassissime di tutti i prodotti che anche
noi consideriamo riciclabili finiscono
effettivamente al riciclo per cui sempre
più persone anche da riviste come questa
che ama rivista americana
sì appunto diciamo la pace del
capitalismo come lo pensiamo oggi si
chiedono sempre di più se sia possibile
creare un'economia che non smette di
creare valore ma che lo faccia senza una
crescita infinita perché il problema del
capitalismo che abbiamo oggi è la
crescita infinita
cosa c'entra il design con tutto questo
c'entra perché nel 1934 un signore ha
creato un paper che il governo federale
americano ha distribuito a tutte le
grandi corporation americane per
spiegare che per incentivare i costumi
dei consumi che già all'epoca soffrivano
perché siamo cinque anni dalla grande
depressione del 29
era necessario creare delle strategie
per far sì che i prodotti che quelle
aziende creavano a livello di
manifattura durassero meno nelle case
degli americani rispetto a quanto
effettivamente avrebbero potuto durare
questa strategia ha funzionato
infatti negli anni cinquanta le macchine
le automobili degli americani duravano
già in media due anni rispetto ai 5 che
duravano invece negli anni 30
tutte le strategie che erano stati
identificati in quel pepe per cercare di
accorciare la vita dei prodotti erano
strategie progettuali quindi strategie
squisitamente di design una ben elenco
qualcuna per esempio la non durabilità
se vogliamo che un prodotto duri di meno
ma non vogliamo svilirne il valore agli
occhi del consumatore lo creiamo un
oggetto che sia molto bello magari anche
molto di valore a livello di materiale
estetico ma che nei punti di giuntura
usa dei materiali di scarsissimo valore
pensate a tutti gli abiti di fast
fashion che compriamo dov'è che si vanno
a rompere nella cerniera dei bottoni
quindi tutti quegli elementi che magari
a cui non facciamo attenzione quando lo
acquistiamo ma che hanno un valore così
basso a livello di materiale che non
permettono la lunga durata del prodotto
il prodotto si potrebbe riparare
ovviamente amore una delle altre
strategie della dell'obsolescenza
programmata era la non riparabilità
degli oggetti
quindi se noi creiamo qualcosa che è
talmente complicato talmente difficile
da disassemblare nessuno mai si sognerà
di ripararlo idem per quanto riguarda le
batterie quanto è facile sostituire le
batterie di certi oggetti tecnologici e
poi c'è anche ovviamente da obsolescenza
percepita se noi acquistiamo un prodotto
che è assolutamente determinato come un
qualcosa di contemporaneo di oggi dal
punto di vista estetico cosa succeda
questo oggetto tra due o tre anni quando
questa estetica di oggi ci ha veramente
stufato
forse ce ne liberiamo giusto e poi anche
l'obsolescenza sistemica quando
acquistiamo un telefono per esempio uno
smartphone e ci capita che dopo due anni
non riusciamo più ad aggiornare il
software perché il peso del software
nuovo è addirittura superiore al diciamo
ai mega che abbiamo di memoria del
telefono
tutto questo è stato fatto per design ok
quindi progettisti in qualche modo sono
stati responsabili magari loro loro
malgrado di questa situazione ci sono
movimenti in questo momento di attivisti
in tutto il mondo che cercano di
combattere questa cosa hanno iniziato
proprio progettisti per esempio c'è un
sito che si chiama ai fix it dove voi
potete trovare tutti gli oggetti
tecnologici in vendita al momento in con
uno score che determina quanto sia il
loro livello di riparabilità pure se per
esempio sono gli air boss della apple
che hanno uno score di adi riparabilità
da 1 a 10 1 sono i più difficili e
impossibili da riparare
volevo arrivare un attimino ad
analizzare anche quello che sono le
strategie che il design proprio nella
contemporaneità di oggi non quelle che
abbiamo visto prima di oggi fa anche pro
al cambiamento climatico anche senza
volere se nel rendere conto tutto il
fenomeno per esempio dell'architettura e
tempo avrei tutti di il temporary store
che abbiamo tutte le fiere tutte queste
situazioni qui si creano momenti
temporanei di di di assembramento oppure
momenti in cui si creano spazi sempre
più caratterizzati con un'estetica del
momento tutto questo favorisce in
qualche modo la creazione di realtà di
di spazi che non hanno una funzione a
lungo termine
ma che durano lo spazio di un secondo
succede persino in architettura questa
architettura e molto famose si chiama
diverso ed è a new york è stata
costruita da thomas heatherwick è un
famosissimo designer architetto se non
lo conoscete è quello che ha fatto di
london bassi quindi veramente una
persona molto
come dire quotata ha costruito questa
architettura esattamente solo perché le
persone possono andarci sopraffarsi la
foto per i social e questo non è una
invenzione perché quando azouz che sono
i muri liste chi ha costruito questa
struttura a pubblica ha pubblicato un
sito da cui si potevano acquistare i
biglietti
eravamo scritto a caratteri cubitali che
ogni immagine fatta da dove sole sud e
verso sarebbe stata proprietà di diaz e
yards questo c'è anche un altro tipo di
problematiche e quella dei business
modus che sono stati sviluppati di
recente per creare valore per esempio
quello del revenue stream
pensiamo ad esempio alle al caffè con le
cialde in un sistema come questo un ma
una un'azienda crea un prodotto di
hardware in questo caso la macchina per
il caffè che dovrebbe costare molto di
più di quello che costa effettivamente
c'è la vende a un prezzo molto basso per
guadagnare poi dal servizio che ci fa
che però non è un servizio digitale come
quello che fa netflix ben servizi di
hardware ci vennero delle cialde che di
fatto vanno prodotte in quantità sempre
più massicce per far guadagnare
all'azienda
ovviamente noi abbiamo un buon caffè
magari ma queste cialde non sono
riciclabili per esempio
e c'è anche l'ultimo problema molto
grave che è quello della comunicazione
in cui il design anche qui un ruolo
molto fondamentale sempre più aziende si
sono rese conto che il consumatore non
vuole più acquistare oggetti non
sostenibili cosa succede allora
cerchiamo share si cerca di mettere
pezze raccontando come sostenibili
oggetti che in realtà non lo sono oppure
cercando di trasformare oggetti che
durano un'eternità in oggetti
biodegradabili quest ultimo esempio che
sembra un assurdo è stato fatto da
carter che ha un'azienda molto famosa di
design che fa oggetti molto belli in
plastica rigida in plastica oggetti che
durano nel tempo questi questi mobiletti
si chiamano componibili di anna castelli
ferrieri sono un classico degli anni 60
chi li ha in casa dagli anni sessanta si
ritiene
sono ancora super funzionali la carta e
li ha fatti adesso in plastica
biodegradabile e ha strillato sulle sue
pubblicità che questi i mobiletti
sarebbero stati persino più degradabili
nelle acque dei fiumi e dei mari il che
sembra abbastanza ridicolo il problema
quindi qual è che fare una comunicazione
sulla sostenibilità degli oggetti è
sbagliato se si parte dal parlare degli
oggetti tantissimi designer io conosco
veramente tanti designer e quasi nessun
designer dice che non vuole fare un
design ecologico tutti i designer sono
pro ambiente
tutti vogliono fare un design verde ma
si concentrano sempre nella maggior
parte dei casi sull'oggetto e cosa
succede che quando ci si concede
sull'oggetto si perde di vista la grande
immagine che è quella del del sistema
produttivo in cui siamo che quello che
va cambiato ve lo spiego adesso con un
esempio quando si vuol dire che un
oggetto ecologico ci si dimentica di
quello che è il suo life cycle
assessment che vuol dire capire
esattamente l'impatto ecologico che ha
un oggetto a partire dal momento
dell'estrazione del materiale fino alla
sua lavorazione fino al suo impacchetta
mente la sua vendita esempio le cannucce
se si chiede a qualunque persona se più
ecologico una cannuccia in plastica o
una cannuccia in metallo chiunque
direbbe la cannuccia metallo è più
ecologica però per fabbricare una
cannuccia in metallo rispetto a una di
plastica ci vogliono 90 volte l'energia
quindi per produrre una in metallo ne
producono vanta in plastica eseguire
come conseguenza la co2 che metto per
produrre una cannuccia in metallo
equivale alla lega la co2 che emette per
creare 150 cartucce in plastica questo
vuol dire che la cannuccia in plastica e
più ecologica o assolutamente no però
vuol dire che la cannuccia in metallo è
più ecologica di quella in plastica solo
se la uso almeno 150 volte e io sfido
quante persone la usano veramente 150
volte quindi il tema e questo non
importa quanto ecologici sono gli
oggetti ma importante che gli oggetti
che vengono fatti d'ora in poi durino ok
e questo è importante anche ed è
importante che questo cambio di
mentalità non parte dei consumatori
innanzitutto perché non siamo
consumatori ma siamo cittadini e noi
come cittadini dobbiamo pretende
che le aziende cambino il loro modo di
fare le cose questa cosa un po sta
succedendo adesso non so se c'è anche a
ferrara ma milano è appena nato la
campagna che si chiama al lock change e
io ho parlato proprio la settimana
scorsa la persona che l'ha ideata si
chiama eric ezechieli e questo signore è
quello che ha portato in italia di
benefit corporation e benefit
corporation sono delle aziende che hanno
messo nella loro mission non solo il
profitto ma anche il bene dell'ambiente
delle persone voi direte vabbè lo fanno
tutti in realtà no nel senso che adesso
anche in italia con queste società
benefit è possibile avere nella propria
legislazione statutaria perché fino ad
ora un'azienda se voi andate proprio a
livello di legislativo aveva l'unico
scopo di responsabilità è quello di fare
profitto per gli azionisti per i soci
adesso se una società si registra come
società benefit ha l'obbligo non solo
morale ma anche proprio economico di
fare bene anche della società
dell'ambiente e delle persone
quindi questa cosa sta cambiando sta
cambiando anche in italia in italia
molto velocemente ci sono tante aziende
in italia che sono già molto radicate in
questo settore perché l'italia è il
paese delle piccole imprese familiari
radicati sul territorio
detto questo su queste tematiche quindi
chi progetta anche deve prendere una
posizione rendersi conto della propria
responsabilità e rendersi conto del
fatto che se noi vogliamo passare da
un'economia lineare a una circolare in
cui praticamente si parla di
condivisione di mantenere i prodotti più
a lungo possibile di riutilizzarli e
infine solo infine di riciclarli cioè
non pensiamo che il riciclo sia di tutto
ma è soltanto l'ultima spiaggia in
un'economia circolare se vogliamo
arrivare a tutto questo sarà necessario
farlo partendo dall'interno quindi
cercando anche chi lavora nelle aziende
e il cambiare il sistema all'interno
delle aziende stesse
cosa vuol dire questo vuol dire creare
per esempio daily e degli oggetti
tecnologici che possano essere
immediatamente riparabili il fair phone
è nato recentemente e se vedete la
differenza nella complessità di rispetto
agli air pos che vi ho fatto vedere
prima vedete che ha notevole eppure un
telefono oppure mettere in rete tutto
quello che sono i materiali di scarto
per esempio in america qui non rho è
un'associazione che ha messo in rete
tutti i produttori
i tessuti americane sia per
l'arredamento che per il fashion e
permette a chi ha bisogno di pezzi di
tessuto di utilizzare quelli di seconda
mano a quelli di scarto che sarebbero se
non finiti alla discarica
lo studio dei materiali ovviamente qui
un esempio di un giovane designer che si
chiama maurizio maurizi
mi ricordo il cognome comunque officina
corpus che la sua azienda e lavora con
il micelio che è un fungo
sostanzialmente per creare una materiale
molto simile alla plastica che eisath
che ha diciamo funzionalità molto simili
e poi ovviamente la cosa più importante
per il passaggio dalla creazione del
vallo del valore del prodotto di
manifattura al servizio cioè la philips
per esempio che ha sempre guadagnato
facendo lampadine adesso che produce dei
luminari che affitta alle grandi spazi
agli aeroporti agli uffici eccetera e
non e guadagna al 70 per cento del
proprio fatturato il 70 per cento dal
servizio che fa per la riparazione per
l'installazione di questi apparecchi di
illuminazione piuttosto che dalla
manifattura quindi la prima parola e
responsabilità che i progettisti con cui
appunto dicevo io parlo spesso e si
dicono sempre responsabile verso
l'ambiente smettono di guardare solo al
prodotto ma guardino e anche noi come
quei cittadini consumatori guardare più
alla diciamo all'immagine allargata
della tela di quello che è la
responsabilità che è la responsabilità
del modo in cui abbiamo creato
l'economia smettere di fare le cose come
le facciamo ora quindi smettere di
disegnare di produrre gli oggetti nello
stesso modo in cui l'abbiamo fatto
finora imparare che cosa recarmi a
circolare che abbastanza complessa vuol
dire progetto alle cose in un modo
diverso ci sono corsi on line tecnico
university di delft per esempio l'età
addirittura gratuitamente li potete
seguire online quando volete perché
perché ormai assolutamente necessario
fare questo cambiamento era necessario
che questo cambiamento parta proprio da
chi progetta gli oggetti e infine
ovviamente essere veramente creativi
creativi non vuol dire fare appunto la
sedia stramba ad apportare al fuori
salone
perché poi la gente ci si possa
divertire bevendo un cocktail nell'alta
essere creativi e proprio pensare a come
portare gli oggetti alla mente
fattura in un modo diverso sostenibile e
circolare e voglio chiudere questo mio
intervento con questa foto scanu è molto
bella di ettore sottsass grandissimo
designer e anarchico che però lavorava
all'olivetti e che ha decisamente
cambiato il nostro modo di percepire la
tecnologia il nostro modo di anche di
percepire gli oggetti ed estetiche del
design ma l'ha fatto e se pur essendo
anarchico all'interno del sistema
quindi io credo che adesso sia proprio
il momento non tanto di fare i
rivoluzionari al di fuori di tirar
pietra eccetera ma proprio di lavorare
all'interno del sistema perché il
momento è giunto è la gente se n'è resa
conto anche le aziende proprio il
momento di spingere verso questo grande
cambiamento che si chiama e con la mia
circolare grazie
[Applauso]